stellt euch vor nicht nur eure
vorgesetzten entscheiden ob ihr eine
gehaltserhöhung bekommt oder nicht
sondern auch euro-kollegen so in etwa
läuft das beim online-händler zalando.de
wehrten sich die mitarbeiter gegenseitig
und das hat dann eben auch einfluss
darauf ob man mehr geld verdient oder
eben auch befördert wird das ist fairer
als nur die chefs entscheiden zu lassen
sagt das unternehmen aber ist jetzt
gerade eine studie rausgekommen im
auftrag der gewerkschaftsnahen
hans-böckler-stiftung die kommt zu einem
anderen ergebnis
darin steht unter anderem dass das zu
ständiger kontrolle und überwachung
führt wie findet ihr das wenn eure
kollegen mit entscheiden können ob er
jetzt eine gehaltserhöhung bekommt oder
nicht schreibt mir gerne hier unten in
die kommentare oder auch alle eure
fragen und wir besprechen das alles mit
einem arbeitsrechtler und zwar mit
professor peter wette ich freue mich
sehr dass sie hier ist das hallo herr
professor werde bevor wir jetzt ins
detail gehen erstmal eine frage an sie
direkt wie finden sie das wenn er zum
beispiel an der uni ihre kollegen ihre
arbeit ständig bewerten würden
also ich finde das gut weil man da mal
ein feedback hat das ist genau das
problem dass man als hochschullehrer hat
dass man da allein im hörsaal steht und
die kollegen oft sehr scheu sind mit
einem drucker zu reden wir haben das mal
gemacht im kleinen kreis ist war sehr
effizient hat sehr viel spaß gemacht war
natürlich macht man fehler auch als
langjähriger vorlesungs profi und das
ist sehr hilfreich wenn die kollegen
einmal sagen ich find das gut wenn das
institutionalisieren würde ist aber sehr
schwer war natürlich zeitmangel da ist
und wenn manche leute auch dazu davor
zurückscheuen da vielleicht mal schlecht
bewertet zu werden unter anderem eine
kritik zu kriegen aber klare aussage ich
finde es gut
genau über solche systeme wollen wir
heute sprechen und wie das system bei
zalando funktioniert das gucken wir
jetzt mal genauer an
im kern funktioniert das
bewertungssystem von zalando so
bewertungen von mehreren kollegen sowie
eines vorgesetzten und einer
selbsteinschätzung wird ein
leistungsbericht erstellt den
begutachtet ein komitee aus
führungskräften und
dann fest ob ein mitarbeiter als top gut
oder low performer eingestuft wird zu
nah nennt zalando dieses system und das
wird von mehreren zalando mitarbeitern
kritisiert in einer studie der
gewerkschaftsnahen hans-böckler-stiftung
kommen sie zu wort ich finde so
unmöglich eigentlich sind es
stasi-methoden ich finde es unverschämt
dass den mitarbeitern halt als
selbstoptimierung stu zu präsentieren
und niemals auch nur mit einer silbe zu
erwähnen dass es eigentlich ein
kontrollsystem ist professor philipp
staab ist autor der studie
für die hat er unter anderem zehn zur
landung mitarbeiter interviewt seine
studie ist nicht repräsentativ gewährt
aber einen einblick in einen der größten
deutschen tech konzerne die gefühlte
überwachung ist nur ein kritikpunkt ein
anderer ist aspekt der sehr wichtig ist
und denen die mitarbeiter mit denen wir
gesprochen haben stark kritisiert haben
ist die intransparenz dieses systems
dass es kein wissen kein wirkliches
wissen darüber gibt wie eigentlich genau
die eigenen stores zustande kommen und
wie die beeinflusst werden können was
natürlich in gewisser weise von den
leuten als dramatisch empfunden wird das
unternehmen widerspricht und betont die
vorteile des hauseigenen
bewertungssystems die
leistungsbeurteilung ist nicht nur im
interesse des arbeitgebers sondern dient
vor allem der fairen behandlung von
mitarbeitern
denn dadurch würden beförderungen und
gehaltserhöhungen nicht von der gunst
einzelner chefs abhängen aber auch
mitarbeiter die bei zu nah nicht
mitmachen wollen kommen auch nicht für
gehaltserhöhungen oder beförderungen in
betracht ob das system den mitarbeitern
hilft ist also umstritten aber arbeits
forscher starb bezweifelt auch dass es
dem unternehmen wirklich nutzt was wir
sehen im umgang mit so nahe ist dass die
beschäftigten vielfach jetzt nach der
einführung dieses systems sozusagen
permanent damit befasst sind sich mit
diesem system und der frage wann werde
ich bewertet usw zu befassen und da geht
relativ viel arbeitszeit für drauf
arbeitszeit die sie vielleicht unter
anderen umständen in sozusagen
produktive tätigkeiten
zalando ist nicht das einzige
unternehmen in dem sich mitarbeiter
gegenseitig bewerten
google arbeitet beispielsweise mit einem
ähnlichen konzept wie sinnvoll unfair
solche verfahren sind diese debatte soll
die neue zalando studie anstoßen
genau diese fragen wollen wir jetzt mit
professor peter werde arbeitsrechtler
besprechen
und der werde ich habe jetzt gerade mal
hier ein blick schon in die kommentare
geworfen
und hier kommt einiges von euch und
ziemlich viel negatives um ehrlich zu
sein
hier schreibt zum beispiel bei facebook
jörg das ist eine aufforderung zum
mobbing toni schreibt das geht gar nicht
was sagt denn der betriebsrat dazu es
gibt aber auch meinungen wie zum
beispiel bei twitter von
medienbeobachter der sagt was jedoch
täglich verbal in unternehmen jetzt
digital sofort und man kann natürlich
auch positiv sehen und könnte sagen na
ja die zeiten wo diejenigen die sich mit
den chefs gut gestellt haben die nach
dem feierabend bierchen getrunken haben
oder zusammen mit dem golfspielen
gegangen sind die zeiten sind jetzt
natürlich vorbei wo noch solche leute
befördert worden sind wie bewerten sie
solche systeme aus sicht eines
arbeitsrechtlers mehr grundsätzlich sind
so bewertungssystem ja nicht verkehrt
wenn es tatsächlich diese drüben 360
grad feedbacks gibt die nach klaren
kriterien ablaufen und die transparenz
sind für alle wo dann mitarbeiter chefs
bewährten mitarbeiter untereinander sich
unter anleitung wie es kommt der
spannende punkt eines eines neutralen
coaches bei zalando ist das ja anders da
ist dann eine kommission aus chef star
die das ergebnis so zu sagen hat dass
der große unterschied dass es dann eben
nicht mehr auf augenhöhe sondern werden
informationen eingesammelt die dann
weitergegeben werden
das verfahren ist für die beschäftigten
nach dem was ich darüber gehört habe
weitgehend intransparent und weiß nicht
genau was passiert ist kommt dann gut
schlecht oder oder mittel raus und daran
hängen dann weitere weitere
gehaltserhöhung und ich meine so viel
beförderung gibt es ja auch nicht ja
nicht so dass man eine super karriere
macht wenn man mal gut abschneidet nach
dem was ich gehört habe sind dann auch
gehaltserhöhung so im ganz normalen
level die bekommt man dann überhaupt nur
wenn man gut bewertet wird und das ist
ein völlig anderes ding und das ist
glaube ich das ärgerliche an der zahl an
der geschichte dass es ihnen kein
offenes paritätisches sich mal
kritisieren im positiven sinn ist
sondern da werden kontrollfragen
gestellter ist etwas dubios wieder an
information abgegeben werden das landet
dann bei irgendwelchen
die irgend was draus machen das hat nun
nichts mehr transparenz zu tun deswegen
finde ich das so ärgerlich weil es
wirklich positive 360 grad feedback
geschichten diskreditiert das verfahren
bald soll die comdirect eine frage von
eric bei youtube der fragt ist das denn
eigentlich egal
das ist so die große frage nicht das ist
eine kontrolle der mitarbeiter ich bin
der mann das ging nicht ohne
einwilligung der beschäftigten ohne
freiwillige einigen dass der
entscheidende punkt und in so einer
drucksituation man kriegt sonst keine
gehaltserhöhung kann von freiwilligkeit
keine rede sein
deswegen sehe ich keinen rechtsgrund
dafür dass zalando das darf es ist auch
nicht fürs arbeitswelt ist erforderlich
da haben ein ganz großes problem mit dem
neuen datenschutzrecht das seit
anderthalb jahren gilt
und ich glaube da wird auch noch eine
intensive debatte darum stattfinden das
muss auch die zuständige
aufsichtsbehörde sich mal angucken weil
das wollte die datenschutzgründen
verordnung gerade hinkriegen dass es
wirklich nur freiwillige einwilligung
gibt die dann entweder beiden dienen
oder den betroffenen rechts vorteil
bringen und nach dem was ich gehört habe
sind ja viele da die überhaupt keine
gehaltserhöhung kriegen das ihren
nachteilen deswegen zweifle ich daran
dass es eine wirksame erlaubnis norm
dafür gibt jetzt wenn wir keine
datenschutz experten erklären sie das
nochmal genau was meinen sie
also es ist so wenn daten über sie
verarbeitet werden wofür der arbeitgeber
keine rechtliche grundlage hat also ihre
gehaltsdaten dafür verarbeitet ihre
arbeitszeiten verarbeiten aber wenn er
mehr will braucht dafür eine rechtliche
grundlage dass kann ihre persönliche
einwilligung sein da sagt der
gesetzgeber die muss freiwillig sein und
nachvollziehbar freiwillig also nicht so
nach dem motto ich bin arbeit über fragt
sie und sie werden dann schon ja sagen
wenn sie karriere machen
das ist bei zalando sicherlich nicht der
fall dass das gegeben ist und dann ist
eine verarbeitung von daten ohne
rechtliche grundlage und ist einfach
schlichtweg unzulässig und das ist bei
zalando die situation und das ist
ungewöhnlich klingen aber nicht jeder
einbildung und so im bereich ist
wirklich freiwillig jetzt ist zalando ja
nicht das einzige unternehmen was euch
so ein system benutzt google zum
beispiel macht das auch oder amazon
beispielsweise sehen sie dann trennt in
die richtung dass das jetzt immer mehr
unternehmen machen es machen immer mehr
unternehmer was ist gerade google und
amazon angesprochen haben immer so vor
einiger zeit auch schon mal in der
öffentlichen diskussion wegen seines
systems sie haben ja ein ganzes stück
zurückgenommen es kommt immer auf den
zusammenhang an wenn das unternehmen
machen die dafür bekannt sind relativ
rigide mit ihren arbeitgebern
arbeitnehmern umzugehen also den wenig
richtig zuzubilligen auf effizienz zu
trimmen
ist das etwas anderes als wenn es ein
unternehmen macht das sagt uns sind
unsere mitarbeiter wird
wichtig und das auch so lebt und dann
kommen ganz unterschiedliche feedbacks
raus diese geschichte bei zalando
computergesteuert mit wenigen fragen
relativ dubiosen auswertungen durch
arbeitgeber unterscheiden sich schon von
dem in anderen unternehmen wo
mitarbeiter drin sind das ist schon mal
der entscheidende punkt in anderen aus
wertungsgruppen sitzen beschäftigte mit
drin sitzt auch jemand vom betriebsrat
mit trainings bei zalando ja so nicht
gibt und da kommt sicher etwas ganz
anderes als wenn du chefs entscheiden
es kommt drauf an wie das system
geschalteter gestaltet ist hier mit
blick auf die kommentare sehe ich dass
es auch ein paar gibt die das durchaus
positiv finden hier schreibt zum
beispiel jasmin bei youtube ich finde es
klasse wenn meine kollegen input geben
können und dieser berücksichtigt wird
meine kollegen wissen doch viel besser
was ich leiste als meine chefs oder auch
stock braker bei twitter schreibt
schlechte bewertungen sind natürlich
auch eine chance um sich verbessern
können
es gibt also auch durchaus argumente für
solche systeme und wir hören uns jetzt
nochmal so ein argument an und zwar von
dem unternehmer heiko fischer der so ein
bewertungssystem entwickelt hat ja muss
damals in der videospielindustrie zum
ersten mal gemacht weil einfach eine
führungskraft gar nicht mehr
durchdringen konnte was die ganzen
experten gemacht haben ja nicht wissen
was macht ein musiker was macht ein
programmierer und das alles bewerten als
wollen wir die bewertung in die hände
der mitarbeiter und belegt hat gesagt
ihr wisst doch viel besser als kollegen
wer gute arbeit macht und wer nicht und
haben sie gefragt wollt ihr ein system
in dem ihr euch gegenseitig positive
wertschätzung ausdrücken können und
haben das tool mit ihnen design also das
von für und durch die mitarbeiter
gestaltet worden das heißt sie haben es
die eigene ihre eigene beste lösung
kreiert und in unserem fall dass das
ganz einfach jedes mal einfach eine
sterne währung hat und sich pro woche
zehn sterne vergeben kann
an leute von denen man denkt ist den
geilen job machen ja das heißt ich
vergebe jetzt einen stern am billigen
sagt du hast was tolles gemacht das
kriegst du auf dein handy und sarko
denke du hast da gerade etwas gutes
gemacht und dafür 1 2 3 4 5 sterne
bekommen
es geht aber auch jeder andere dass du
da was gutes getan hat das heißt das hat
die positiven effekt auf die kultur und
die schärfsten sinn der mitarbeiter auf
dem fokus auf das positive zu richten
herr werden können sie nachvollziehen
was der heiko fischer erklärt ja ich
kann das nachvollziehen das klingt ja
auch schon wieder anders also wenn
mitarbeiter sich wirklich untereinander
direkt bewerten hat das ja auch was
wirklich konstruktives wenn der chef
vielleicht dann auch was davon
mitbekommt und die wertschätzung sieht
und das tatsächlich auf augenhöhe
stattfindet in so ein prozess halte ich
das für durchaus gut dass man
miteinander redet und auch mal positiv
wie negativ sich kreta sie kritisiert
dass hier nur die nur der verbesserung
ist was anderes als wenn das sozusagen
in ein anonymes system rein geht ein
computer das ganze auch noch erfasst
werden die daten auch anders ausgewertet
und wenn dann bewertungen rauskommen die
unmittelbar auswirkungen aufs gehalt
haben das ist hier in dem beitrag ja
nicht gesagt worden sondern das geht nur
wertschätzung das ist sehr positiv
es geht aber nicht darum ob man dann
zwei prozent mehr gehalt kriegt oder
nicht und ein krieg so bewertung wir
sofort eine ganz merkwürdige touch
interessanterweise gehen hier wirklich
eigentlich alle kommentare von euch hin
und her in so eine richtung wo ganz
viele sagen ja leistung durch angst das
wäre nicht gut das ist ein offenes
umfeld geben müsse damit so was
funktioniert
wie könnte denn so ein system aussehen
wie müsste das geschaltet gestaltet sein
dass man quasi das positive mit
rausnimmt auch so mitarbeiter
gegenseitiges bewerten ohne dass man
diese negativen konsequenzen hat gibt es
auch positivbeispiele ja es gibt so 360
grad feedback gespräche dass das
modewort dafür wirklich alle miteinander
sitzen und in der strukturierten form
einfach auch kritik positive negative
hinweise gegeben werden die dann aber
moderiert mit allen miteinander
ausgewertet werden oder vielleicht auch
in einzelgesprächen aber auch die
einzelgespräche sind strukturiert und
wie gesagt das sind dann oft auch
neutrale dritte die dabei sind wo man
keine sorge haben muss der haut mich
jetzt in die pfanne oder aus dem betrieb
vertrauenspersonen dann kriegt das
sofort in ganz anderen touch wenn einem
einer dem man vertraut sagt du immer
deine kollegen haben alle gesagt du
machst du einen super job aber du bist
morgens immer schlecht gelaunt das nervt
alle oder sowas nicht da kann hiermit
umgehen oder auch inhaltlich du bist zu
langsam du bist so schnell das feld hier
auf dann kann man damit umgehen kann was
dazu sagen wenn es da nicht ein
vorgesetzter ist vor dem man auch angst
haben muss sondern wie man der auch auf
augenhöhe begegnet kann man die kritik
vielleicht auch annehmen oder kann auch
sagen ich bin anderer meinung also
offene gesprächssituationen das sagen
haben alle die gutes machen und nicht
sozusagen strukturierte geschichte die
nur auf gehalt sieht einfach mal genau
weiß wenn ich damals schlecht
wird mir nicht etwa geholfen meine
leistung zu verbessern oder meinen meine
performance sondern da muss ich dafür
sorge haben dass ich keine
gehaltserhöhung krieg oder vielleicht
auch aus dem betrieb entfernt werde und
das ist natürlich eine ganz schlechte
voraussetzt machen sie die erfahrung
dass solche 360° gespräche dass die
häufiger stattfinden dass mehr
unternehmen dass immer mehr unternehmen
das machen wir dann eben die er diese
anderen softwaresysteme es ist so ein
modetrend also software neben eigentlich
relativ wenige unternehmen auch diese
360 grad feedback sind nicht immer
beliebt bei beschäftigt man hört dass
immer ich muss schon wieder so was
machen ich habe so das gefühl das ist
ein trend der kommt weil man sich
verspricht von systemen das ist alles
gut gemacht und warten sie mal ab was da
auf uns zukommt wenn erstmal künstliche
intelligenz in solchen systemen da ist
die systeme stehen schon vor der tür die
das dann alles direkt bewerten unser
gespräch jetzt auch anhand der emotionen
der stimme bewerten würden da kommen
dann ganz gruselige dinge raus und die
sind schon in amerika und wog solche
systeme in deutschland wird darüber
nachgedacht die sind bloß rechtlich
einfach ein problem und unzulässig und
da kommt noch ganz andere dimension auf
uns zu wenn man sich dann so verspricht
ein computer sagt ihm dann die gut
mitarbeiter sind nicht glaubt das nicht
aber wir werden uns mit ihm stellen
müssen sogar noch eine zukunftsvision
herr professor werde ich freue mich sehr
dass sie heute hier waren unsere fragen
beantwortet haben schon gern gekommen
sehr schön und ich bedanke mich ganz
natürlich auch bei euch allen für eure
fragen die ihr hier fleißig geschrieben
habe und eure meinungen eure erfahrungen
und was ihr davon haltet und ich würde
mich natürlich freuen wenn ihr beim
nächsten live stream auch wieder dabei
wird der findet nächste woche statt am
dienstag und dann ist da nie wieder für
euch da
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser leistung gefallen
hat dann gefällt euch vielleicht auch
dieser hier da ging es darum ob studium
oder ausbildung besser ist oder ihr
klickt euch mal hier rein da haben wir
über hartz4 sanktionen diskutiert oder
ihr lasst uns einfach hier ein abo da
das wird uns freuen